ceasefires won't they're not there on
they're not on the horizon right now
but they may be in a couple of weeks
they may be
a little bit longer than that and it
will all depend on two things
the war
of course
where that's going uh your guess is as
good as mine and the talks
because i'm
absolutely sure that is only on the
basis of some
minimum confidence building that might
come out of those talks and i'm being
hopeful here
as opposed to objective
that you will see the the beginning of
the russian federation turning its
turning its eyes on potential ceasefires
so we need to watch the talks very very
carefully turkeys is is is a is a very
very important uh
aspect to this there isn't
in classical mediation terms there isn't
a mediation really going on between the
russians and the ukrainians
in the way that you and i understand
mediation but the turks come closest to
it i think of all member states and of
course it's important to them and that's
why they're doing so well and that's why
the secretary general had this detailed
discussion yesterday as you know with
president erdogan and that's not the
first time he's had that
and i'll be following up to see
on the basis of that call is there any
way in which the united nations
can contribute
perhaps with turkey or in any other way
to that process that vital talks process
that may be slightly stumbling at the
moment but has certainly got to be where
we put our hopes for the future
the russians continue
we have it we have a cell in moscow and
we have done as you know for some time i
think i've spoken about it in this room
before
um and they continue daily and my
colleagues continue daily
to plan for convoys to move
and we've had a number of successful
movements of convoys but completely
inadequate
in terms of the overall requirement
and we have a system of humanitarian
notification we notify the russians we
notify the ukrainians and if they don't
come back and say no it's too dangerous
we go we do that we do the movement
so there was a lot of discussion about
that i think the i think it would be
fair to say that right now
if i could speak for the russian
authorities
um they are not uh not putting us local
ceasefires at the top of their agenda
not yet
our priority right now and you will see
plans to do this
um in the next couple of days is to get
a convoy through into donetsk
and to supply from there
into luhansk and into those different
areas
and then to stay